hello and welcome to the chicken science
show where today i'm here in cambridge
uh to speak with daniel ives to see a
multinational scientist where they're
using machine learning to try and
identify safe drugs for cellular
reprogramming so before we speak with
daniel we're going to take a little
nice tour inside the building
cool
[Music]
as long as you obviously escape velocity
right so you're like
trying to like help everybody see this
and get up there because it's going to
be great
and so yeah nathan sort of qualifies
i qualify
it's a little bit loose about who gets
to be in this or not it's mostly
you know he said he doesn't
throw up with us anyway so
that's that and then that's elon musk
got really old
[Music]
so hi daniel thank you for joining me
today in person and welcome to the
chicken science show thanks for having
me
awesome um so yeah it's great to
actually be ourselves in person for once
um
and we're actually here currently in
cambridge where um we both have i guess
ties to now um and also we're somewhat
related in that we both initially
studied biochemistry um and so i guess
my first question was where did that
interest come from um
what do you into the field of
biochemistry and then subsequently you
did
your phd focus on mitochondria and so i
guess could you elaborate on what your
phd project was all about
sure so
the reason why i got interested in
biochemistry was actually very boring
which was i was good at biology i was
good at chemistry like out of the
subjects i was taking
and i just thought well
just go with what's working and i was
very interested on the biological side
in particular but chemistry was very
challenging um you know there were some
interesting details but it was mostly
about the biology so biochemistry was
really
interesting because it was like it was
greater depth on the biology so
you know i'd almost resented learning
all this chemistry stuff but in the in
the when you frame it in the context of
biology it's very interesting so
um i did biochemistry and uh
i was good at that
um and then i got i think i went all the
way to masters and around the time i
needed to decide what i was going to do
after that
aubrey de gray who's a cambridge
geneticist and written a book called
ending acting ageing
and it was really like a call to arms
you know it was like aging isn't an
inevitable process
you know you and me we're not like a
rock subject or entropy or we don't just
turn to dust like we can externalize
entropy
um there's no reason why we shouldn't
keep ourselves going the way you could
keep our vehicle going i like classic
cars you can keep them going
and it was captivating this book it's
like i really you know really sort of
caught my attention and
after reading that i was like look this
is the way that i can really leverage my
skills you know like let's focus on this
and i think one of the top
you know uh
types of age link damage like listed in
the book was uh mutations in the
mitochondrial genome like that was the
hardest one to crack so i was like well
i'll do that
um
and there was a project in cambridge uk
not cambridge uk so the mitochondrial
biology unit in cambridge
actually sponsored by aubry um
and i applied to that project but by the
time i showed up it was too late so
basically the first student had
encountered technical difficulties
they'd had to discontinue the project
and i didn't really have a plan b i just
wanted to do that project
but sort of in my morning period and i
just found other projects in the lab
which seeked to address the same problem
which is as you get older mutations in
the mitochondrial genome accumulate
and there was an alternative way to sort
of try and fix this problem and that's
where i got started with my phd
and
it went well it went well so
um
there's a publication came out recently
like this work started way back in 2009
so it just shows you like how long it
can take yeah i think it was like three
three or four post docs had to sort of
come in and lead it so i sort of
i wouldn't say abandoned [ __ ] but like i
had to i had to
go and do my own thing i wanted to
basically work in aging and the lab
wanted to work on rare diseases but
there was a few post docs and that has
now published
and it's funny because the publication
is almost the palatable version of
events you know which is actually
i did a very messy and i think more
interesting thing we discovered that we
could actually
use small molecules to get rid of
mitochondrial dna mutations right but
there's still a lot of black box so
these poor postdocs had to try and
reverse engineer this black box
so it would be fit for publication
because nobody wanted to know about the
messy way we'd create this black box and
found this
found this molecule and but once there
was a bit of a bit more you know story
around it and mechanism that was that
was more palatable
i think in the early days i was actually
accused of just arriving at this sort of
black box by pure luck someone was like
well you could have just got lucky and i
couldn't disprove that
but i actually worked hard on the
bioinformatics sort of self-taught you
know self-taught genetic enrichment
analysis there's something called
ingenuity pathway analysis i saw it took
on
um and we arrived at a prediction of
what was going on and it worked
so
maybe i didn't get lucky but i feel like
i'm putting a lot of work as well so it
doesn't really matter we found out
something that worked so i guess it's
about mentioning then that so we also
have our dna in our nucleus which has
our genetic information but it's also
worth pointing out that we do have these
separate mitochondria that also have
their own dna and i think one of the
interesting things about mitochondrial
dna is the fact that we have multiple
copies of mitochondria in a cell and so
some of them might get mutations and
some of them might not and so you get a
thing called like heteroplasmy but then
the other thing with mitochondria they
only
code for 13 genes is that right or
around 13 different genes
so they're quite small compared to our
whole nuclear genome so
like what is the kind of arguments for
mitochondrial mutations actually being
important to the aging process
so the most provocative
finding was that if you turn up these
mutations like i think it's like two and
a half two and a half thousand times
higher than you would experience
physiologically at least for a mouse you
get a premature aging phenotype so it's
called the mutator mouse
so basically it just exhibits all the
features of aging all the phenotypes of
aging and it was i think it was a nature
front page it was like aging solved
by just very presumptuously you know
it's like aging soft but um
there's lots of ways
to create sorry premature aging
phenotype
um because like mutant nuclear envelope
proteins like lamins there's a mutant
lamin creates an aging phenotype there's
lots of project models like double
strand break repair deficiencies create
a kind of aging phenotype
so
you know i guess there's all those
things going on but
because these mutations accumulate with
age and when you turn them up you create
an aging phenotype it was sort of very
provocative at the time it's like 2004.
okay
so
i guess you know i had almost
made my bed at that stage when i was at
the mitochondrial biology unit because i
was interested in aging and that's why i
was working on mitochondria
you know that was my world and i was
like well you know it's it's almost
confirmation bias right so you know you
say something else
and
i didn't know about the aging clock at
this stage right this this sort of
relatively unbiased way to measure aging
so
i guess in the absence of that it's like
everybody was in contention it's like it
might be the mutations or it might be
senescent cells or might be autophagy
and so i was just you know just going
a million miles an hour with you know my
route
um
but we you know we were able to find uh
sort of molecules that could
basically get rid of these these damage
types so yeah the mitochondrial genetic
system is very interesting like
thousands of copies potentially of a
mitochondrial genome in the cell versus
uh just two copies
of a gene right
diploid nucleus and it's almost like
having two operating systems because in
the nucleus if you only got two copies
and one goes wrong that's a big deal
that's like 50 of the information gone
but in the mitochondrial system you can
just
get rid of one copy you can sort of
alter you know buy autophagy get rid of
one of the mitochondria just you know
clear it out
and then they can reproduce and
repopulate so
it's actually more like a
um
like an ecosystem right you've got like
all these mitochondria sort of
coexisting with each other
and what tends to happen is one of the
mitochondria gets a mutation in its
genome that genome gets some sort of
advantage you know so
yeah the genome creates a mitochondria
which isn't as good right it's not as
functional
but it replicates faster or it's you
know somehow it's able to replicate
faster
and it and then it just wipes out the
cell so when you look at aged tissue and
you see a a cell that's deficient in
energy production which sort of uh
assignment the mitochondria going bad
you go and look in that cell and it's a
it's a point mutation the mitochondrial
genome but in every single one of those
thousand genomes so
it's like you know there was some event
and then that was like an internal
cancer it wiped out that cell and you go
to a different cell in the laser tissue
there's a different point mutation which
is
wiped out that cell so it's listed sort
of instability in that genetic system
right you know it's sort of waiting to
happen sooner or later like in a
probabilistic way
um
so yeah mitochondria basically
they have all these copies which is
great for redundancy but then they have
this fragility which is like if one copy
takes hold it's a big problem and
there's no repair you know relatively
little repair there so exactly yeah
because i think when i was talked about
it in undergrad um there are certain
like mitochondrial associated diseases
and they occur with age because it takes
time for like the mutated copy of the
mitochondria to then obviously kind of
like take over
um the cell in terms of the copy number
compared to like the wild type
equivalents yeah there are surveillance
systems in the cell so these these these
mutant genomes they sort of they just
they just hide below the surface of
those surveillance systems so they're
not so dysfunctional that
these surveillance systems pick them up
easily
it's like pink pink one parking
yes or mitochondria so basically if you
if you have a massively depolarized
mitochondria this just scoops it up like
immediately but if you're on this sort
of
middle ground or gray zone where you're
still making a bit of energy but not
as much as you should be
you can sort of be a bad genome and then
over time like slowly take over it's you
know like a
sort of insidious might take over yeah
and so you spoke about this reason
publication that i believe came out
literally the end of last year and so i
know you describe um two deoxy d-glucose
as being one of these compounds that can
like somehow bias the cell to get rid of
the mutated copies so like is that
something we should be really excited
about is in a potential therapeutic or
what are your thoughts on it yeah so two
dioxide glucose is a double-edged sword
so um
so the the way we even like
got to two dioxide glucose was sort of
interesting so basically it's a cancer
cell line called a549
that spontaneously figured out how to
get rid of
damaged mitochondrial genomes yeah so if
you if you populate this this uh this
cell type with a metered genome and a
multi genome over time which is like a
period of months it will get rid of the
mutant genome like repeatedly and
reliably it will do this
which is the opposite to all the other
cell lines surveyed so like other cell
lines like 143b osteosarcoma
and there's some other ones they all do
the opposite which is if you put a
mixture of a mutant genome in a multi
genome the mutant will increase over
time and this this will happen in
typical cells as well otherwise these
things wouldn't persist so the way that
i found two 2d oxygen glucose was that i
took transcriptones from the ncbi gi
which is a big public database for the
transcript teams so i took them for a549
there's loads of them right because
loads of people use these cells for
different experiments you just take the
control yeah just there were like 30
transcriptomes for that and then i took
an equivalent number of transcriptomes
for the other cell types to do the
opposite and then i just did
differential expression and i did gene
set enrichment analysis
and it was actually just with gene cell
enrichment analysis that we saw that the
unfolded protein response was
really upregulated in a549 versus the
other cell types
and then i it was no no no more
complicated than this i was like just
bought a bunch of
stuff off sigma that activated the
unfolded protein response two deoxy
glucose with one of them but there were
plenty of other things i tested but it
was only two dioxic glucose that
basically re-capitulated
what the a549 cell line was doing like
there were actually things that
activated this unfolded protein response
which didn't reduce the mutations yeah
so it's not it's not as simple as
unfolding protein response equals get
really getting rid of these mutations
but something about the 2d oxygen
glucose is
you know this is why people like well
you got lucky
and they might be right but it does work
and the moment you get something to work
you can use that as a way to interrupt
you know now we can induce it on demand
we can start studying the different
features of the cell and you know start
reverse engineering the process right we
just induced the phenomenon that we're
interested in let's see what different
pathways in the cell were doing and that
was sort of the
that was the
reverse engineering project that
followed right which i wasn't
sort of deeply involved in because i was
doing stuff with shift and aging it was
you know once we knew the utility
existed or out of these molecules um for
me it was always about aging you know
let's figure out
basically let's figure out what's going
on here under the black box and this is
this is the other side of 2d oxide
glucose so a long time ago
i think it was nih investigators
actually
tried to use 2d oxygen glucose as a
caloric restriction memetic right so
because it's glucose
yeah so you just change it slightly and
it fools the cell into thinking uh
basically blocks out i think it blocks
glycolysis yeah that's that right so
basically the cell thinks that it's just
run out of glucose and it sort of you
know does all these things
so they
they they were hoping this would be like
the chloride restriction of metal like
we don't have to be hungry all the time
to get the benefits you just take two
octo case
and
they gave it to rats but unfortunately
in the rats they got cardiac toxicity so
um they started getting vaccination of
the heart issue
and they started dropping dead before
before the wild type animals dropped
yeah so i think it was actually
my working memory on this is a bit hazy
and
then they they started looking at
artificial sources of 2d oxygen glucose
versus natural sources like was there
some chemical in the preparation that
was causing this um but the short story
was there was basically um the cardiac
tissue in particular takes on a lot of
glucose so therefore it enriches two
dioxygen glucose to much higher levels
than any of the other tissues experience
and actually you sort of need a
goldilocks zone of glycolysis you don't
want to shut down the whole thing and
quite high energy tissue
and
so but you know that was the idea for
quite restriction but like you know the
reason we used it was completely
different like we were just trying to
emulate this weird cell line called a549
you know the unfolded protein response
um
but
there is a there is a light at the end
of the tunnel which is you can add an
additional compound to sort of get
around some of these issues with two
oxygen glucose and
i should know the paper better but
there's another compound you can add and
i think there are there's there's a
there's a quite a well advanced
initiative now to run a clinical trial
with two deoxy glucose basically
treating patients that have a pathogenic
mitochondrial genome that basically
causes a rare disease called milas okay
so you inherit this from your mum
because your mum gives you your
mitochondria so and they're going to try
and use tedious glucose and this sort of
safety enhancer at the same time and
so that's great that's great you know so
that's actually gone somewhere
um
but i'm not i'm not super involved in
that anymore because we went a different
direction exactly yeah so i mean yeah
that's really interesting um and i
didn't know that much about tdrt
blueprints that was really interesting
to hear and having worked with a549
sales as well that's also quite
interesting i didn't know that about
those sales yeah like what is it about
the evolutionary history of that cell
line yeah because it's a lung cell
so it's lots of oxygen so you know if
you've got a lot of oxygen um
and you can use your mitochondria right
you know maybe that's a selective
advantage i don't know like if you know
if you've got functional mitochondria
that allows you to grow faster as a
tumor i don't know
i can only speculate on that but it is
intriguing the
fact that only is it's actually unique
just this
lung cancer cell line
has found out a way to mix up its genes
in such a way that it can enrich
like the wild type mitochondria at the
detriment of the mutant where other
other cellulites don't do that yeah yeah
for sure um but i guess yeah we should
probably uh chef flavor to shift um as
um you've already brought it off on
conversation and so
you've you know at the time you finished
your phd and now you're interested in
mitochondria still when it comes to
aging so
how did you get from that position to
starting shift bioscience
yeah so whilst i was in the academic
laboratory like looking into the oxygen
glucose um
i i knew about the mutated mouse yeah so
like the mutated mouse was this
premature aging model
um
yeah that was caused by mitochondrial
dna mutation so the models i were using
were basically rare disease models so it
was a milas mutation it's a point
mutation that causes rare disease and we
use this to see you know does 2d oscar
glucose reduce level mutation or
increase it and when we got something
working there for me that's like that
was the moment it's like we found a
technology
that can help aging and i just wanted to
do the equivalent experiment in
mutatomites but these are very expensive
experiments like you've got to get a
bunch of mice and you've got to figure
out how to dose them properly and all
these things so
it was sort of it was very risky it was
high budget it just wasn't it wasn't the
sort of thing that the laboratory i was
working at could bear it's really it was
really for me to go that direction so
um for various reasons my postdoc was
cut short by one month just one month
okay i got a fanta fantastic redundancy
payment it was like ten thousand pounds
and you don't get you don't pay tax on
it either so it's just ten thousand
pounds so um
i wasn't able to do mutated mouse
experiments with that but i was able to
like at least look in a second system i
think it was like a parkinson's
fibroblast cellulite
so we had an inclination that there'd be
a mutation right the mitochondrial
genome of parkinson's cell line which in
hindsight was actually quite high risk
you know that hypothesis was nowhere
near near
assured and we actually found in the
only available parkinson's idiopathic
parkinson's cell line we found a point
mutation in the mitochondrial genome it
was like nd5
and
then we were like oh wow so you know
we've oh we've got this thing working in
the mirror you know in the minor setting
will it work in a general sense right
will it work for any mutation not just
mean us so we we basically
um
we we we tested i think it was two
deoxygluce first you know in this and
there's parkinson's sideline and
unfortunately it killed the cell line
right so these it's a fibroblast from a
very old individual with a disease right
so two deoxy glucose pretty severe
anyway um so anyway it killed the cell
line and then we had to basically go on
the search for
structurally similar compounds to
tedious glucose we were like okay what
is it about 2d oscar d phases
interesting well let's stay within the
structural realm so we found some
compounds that were structurally similar
but didn't have this extreme viability
issue and so one of those compounds
called sv200
we treated these parkinson's uh
fibroblasts and we got rid of this
mutation yeah so so whatever this
activity was it wasn't specific for me
in us we could we could look at yeah we
could we could you know deal with that
mutation we could deal with that
mutation and the moment we knew that we
could we could it was independent of the
type of mutation
that was the de-risking step before the
mutated mouth so the mutated amount is
just mutations everywhere on this genome
and so like it was we needed to know
that this was a general activity against
mutations or just specific mutations
and then
we basically just went around
asking people for money
so i think my dad put in a bit of money
my uncle put on a bit of money and we
got some donations
i asked my girlfriend at the time she'd
give me her life savings and she said no
which was the correct answer she said
you should talk to an investor who can
afford to lose this money because it was
a very high-risk project at the time i
thought you know we were on to this was
going to be like this was going to be it
um but she said to go to an investor and
um because i got uh you know my my dad
was a serial entrepreneur right so quite
a long time ago he has a network in
cambridge i was very fortunate we could
just you know he could see what was
going on when he was getting interested
because he's got a biochemistry degree
as well but he went into like mobile
technology where he didn't go into that
but he could see this was getting
interesting and so we're actually able
to connect with jonathan milner who in
cambridge uk
he's a life science angel here so he
founded the uh
the company ab cam which was a unicorn
and then he obviously did well i need
his angel investing off the back of that
and we went to talk to jonathan about
this and he said this is too early i'm
not ready for this yet but
if you manage to do anything with the
small amount of extra money you're about
to spend because we just we did have a
little bit extra money he said i'd like
first refusal you know this becomes a
company so we went back actually made it
made a bit of progress and he put in the
first chunk of money
but you know we actually established
shift right in 2017 at that stage
um
yeah so that's that's how shift started
um
i'm going to stop there just in case i
just keep going
cool yeah so um so initially you had the
idea of fixing on mitochondria still
as being the i guess like the focus
point for finding some kind of
therapeutic
but then at some point you've now
shifted gears more so just like selling
and reprogramming and looking at using
machine learning and uh gene expression
data to try and find an answer instead
so
pardon the pattern but how did you like
shift your focus um between these two
different areas
yeah so just just to make sure there's
no confusion the term shift doesn't come
from our propensity to pivot as a
company so it actually comes from the
mitochondrial dna heteroplasmy now which
is the coexistence of two populations a
mitochondria each you know one with a
mutant genome one of the ones hygiene
and it's called heteroplasmy shift when
you're able to change okay those
proportions so the a549 shifts to wild
type and another sound shift above and
but for various reasons shift seems to
work in a lot of different contexts
um like you know like i don't know
we've got a driver clock
and yeah anyway just anyway just it does
seem that there's no need to change it
right now it just seems to have
its place at the table
uh so when we when we start with
jonathan milner um
i was absolutely adamant right this was
the solution you know this was the point
of maximum leverage like this is how
we're going to solve solve aging
just have to get rid of these
mitochondrial mutations
but very quickly it was actually
jonathan that
you know sort of
put this across my desk he was like have
you heard of the aging clock because
he's all reads still reads all the
journals right you see them on his desk
he said have you heard of the agent
clock and i was like what is the agent
and this was 2017 so it wasn't like it
had just come out it was like four years
ago and like four years have passed and
the moment we found out about the aging
clock it was like
this is amazing right because now you've
got the ability to measure aging so for
us we had a very narrow hypothesis right
mitochondrial mutations
a big cause of aging you know or like
one of the biggest causes
if we reverse that we're going to invest
a lot of the process so let's qualify
that using the clock because the the
clock is as close as we can get to a
robust compass you know like what is
asian what is the name of it you're
talking about the epigenetics epigenetic
agent crock yeah so steve wolves
epigenetic asian club
um
but the experiment we wanted to run was
using mouse samples so we we basically
did the mutated last experiment and
excitingly we showed that we could slow
down uh the visible aging phenotypes in
this mice so it was like wow it actually
works in the mouse like i think i was
advised by my my external phd examiner
that this was a
don't do this experiment it's high high
risk but that's almost this is the type
of you set up a startup to do these
things right but i did it and we
actually affected these aging things so
i was like oh wow so it's actually
amazing like you've got this mouse
experiment
and you get updates and you see that the
treatment right so you've just had a
hypothesis right and you see the
treatment these mice are better off it's
actually pretty like that's it's quite
an amazing feeling and like we didn't
know that this wasn't the be all the
end-all of aging at the time so it was
even you know it was like oh wow like
this reinforces that we're doing the
right thing
um
but we wanted to make sure that we
weren't accused of just affecting aging
in this particular mouse model because
people always complain right get it to
work in a mouse doesn't really mean
anything it's good for the mouse
but we're not mice right so are we you
know are we doing all this for the mice
we're not it's for us
so
we wanted to use an agent clock to say
to show that not only was this mouse
model
affected by this therapeutic but the
clock was affected and therefore
physiological aging was affected right
because the clock represents
physiological aging so uh wolf reich
who's actually a local academic at the
baby institute and now he's moving into
the sort of outsourced labs and he he
came up with the first multi-tissue
mouse clock
which which allowed us to basically you
know measure
uh the clock in our mouth samples and
but we had to embed somebody in his lab
because he didn't have any spare hands
we couldn't just send them samples right
so he said why don't you
send one of your
people right to learn what we're doing
you know so you know just minimize the
amount of bandwidth required from his
side
so send them and they can learn it and
they can do the clock measurements
and and we did this so
we got a really interesting result from
this experiment so
on the one hand it was good on the one
on the other hand it was the beginning
of the end for this this approach so
um we did slow down the clock by 50 in
this mouse model yeah
and on the back of that we actually set
up a follow-on experiment in aged b6 jmi
so aged physiological mice so you can
actually buy
like 78 week or mice from the jackson
laboratory just off the shelf they
maintain a cohort and so we repeated
this experiment in these aged mice
and but whilst whilst whilst that was
going on because he still still takes a
long time and we showed that the mutator
mouse didn't show any acceleration of
the clock at all right so the clock
basically said that these these mice
that visibly look very much older than
they should be and according to the
clock they were exactly the age like
exactly the chronological age
so even though we slowed the clock down
in this mouse model this mouse model
didn't show acceleration of aging right
which is you know that's the whole the
mutated mouse has way more mutations it
should have
a much higher clock reading so
um
it turned out later like when we did the
wild type mouse experiment that we
didn't slow the clock down in the wild
type mice it was only in the mutated
mice we could slow the plot down
and but the major finding was that the
mutator mouse wasn't
accelerated aging according to what the
clock represents so it wasn't the
acceleration of physiological aging
yeah there's an acceleration of the
aging phenotype there wasn't an
acceleration of the clock and we really
put a lot of faith in the clock like you
know we for us it was like look we have
to affect the clock first yeah and then
we can do other things and that's great
but to not affect the clock it's just
too risky down the line like we want to
be focusing on the absolute problem that
you and me have right i see not
something in the mouse so
for us that was there was a lot of
soul-searching um also known as pivot
point or existential crisis many names
for it and and
you know you have to ask yourself
serious questions which is like why am i
doing this
and so we had a quite you know there's a
there's a sort of fork in the road do we
continue to develop this type of
therapeutic which ultimately belongs
in rare disease patients yeah you know
well that's that's where it was born and
that's you know where had the most
utility or do we you know stay true to
the mission here you know which was the
initial mission of shift
uh solve
solve aging um
i know people a bit funny about the
language now but let's just you know
soul aging
and for us it was always about that's
where we get the energy it's like it'd
be amazing if we could
bring age under our control yeah it was
up to us how much we let ourselves
unravel you know that just changes
everything it's like the equation just
changes for everything
so
we try to like learn the lesson from
this result you know because actually
using a clockwise we were trying to face
the music right it's actually a brave
step
you know it's it's sometimes it's quite
hard to
stare the truth in the face
um so
you know we wanted to learn the lesson
from this and actually the clock had
told us a valuable lesson which was
we're not as clever as we think we are
yeah
you know we like to think we're clever
especially at cambridge university like
you know like you saw with all of the
history right while i got to cambridge i
remember my parents and oh my god
oh you're so clever
but no you're not so you know nature's
nature's got a lot of mysteries that
aren't you know it's not it's not always
brain power so the lesson that we'd
experienced was like we just been able
to fail fast right we weren't we're no
longer the walking dead is the best way
to fail
yeah so we we're no longer the walking
dead yeah because the clock has said all
right it's giving us some valuable
information this isn't the way forwards
but we'd actually use this clock in a
very narrow sense so once you've got the
ability to measure aging the
like the potential of that isn't just to
ask one question at a time the like the
the full potential of the clock is to
ask all of the questions right and so
you know like biologically it's it's
something like a functional screen for
aging or a crisper screen for aging so
um you know you can knock out gene one
in the genome see what it does to aging
knock out number two gene two in the
genome see what it does to aging go
through every one of the twenty thousand
genes and assign a relationship to aging
and and if you do that you can let the
biology do the talking right let the
biology tell you where to
focus and say start building as far as
your targets are concerned so
for us that was the lesson from the
clock right and that that was that was
the product of the pivot you know so it
was like well
let's focus on clocks yeah and
we we had a particular technical problem
we needed to solve um to do this crispr
screen so we could have we could have
done a crisper screen with the existing
methylation clock yeah the hall vast
clock but every clock measurement
actually requires a large number of
cells in the dish it's like millions of
cells for one clock measurement so it's
actually like a 10 centimeter dish for
one o'clock plot measurement and so you
actually need like 20 000 dishes right
to do a christmas screening it was just
sort of unmanageable um from our
standpoint i mean maybe you could do it
like a human genome project type thing
um but for us it was just you know that
was unmanageable however tanex genomics
had launched a machine called the
chromium which allowed you to do single
cell crispr
and simultaneously get a transcriptome
from each cell so you can knock out one
gene in the cell get a transcriptome
knock out another gene themselves get a
transcriptome and and this this is
actually offered a path to a christmas
screen for aging because
though they weren't as well used and not
as celebrated you could create aging
clocks from gene expression all the
transcriptomes so i think alex zedd from
insilico had created a you know a
transcriptome clock and others had
created transcriptome clocks but they
were they were less accurate they were
always tissue specific they sort of
became the b team and then the
methylation clocks you know they always
got better and like multiple species
uh you know mortality revenge those
sorts of things like that really became
the center of focus but
we we wanted to
do a crispr screen for aging and
therefore gene expression based clocks
became very interesting very quickly so
if we could create a single cell
aged clock based on the transcriptome we
could do a christmas screen for aging
and actually find the aging biology you
know so
like it's almost the key to the biology
then became a gene based uh clock yeah
a single cell because it had to work on
this on the single cell christmas screen
and fortunately for us tony weskere at
stanford
deposited this amazing data set called
the tabling murasanis so for those that
aren't familiar it's a
single cell transcriptome of the mouse
by every single cell from the mouse at
the transcription level
over an aging time course so it's like i
think it was like two or three million
dollars right to fund all of this and it
was made publicly available
and we could use that single cell uh
transcriptome data to try and create
clocks
and this is where
this is where brendan swain comes in so
brendon was originally an intern at
shift i think in 2018 it was actually
relatively recently after we started
and and we initially got interested in
clocks because you know we were using
clocks to audit our
hypothesis we were also trying to share
it with people because the clocks were
not familiar to people right and
everybody else was trying to figure out
how to use clocks and we we were using
them for our own purposes
because we wanted to do the therapy side
and
but yeah he got interested in clocks
started playing around with the horvath
uh linear i think it's linear regression
um you know all the code and stuff like
that um and then we we simultaneously
got interested in this tablet mirror
sentence and we always combine the two
right like let's
just take this all off the shelf
machine learning method right which is
generating clogs it's just supervised
machine learning
and uh you know try and try and make
this work for single-cell transcriptome
data and actually we yeah brandon was
he's self-taught so he's a biologist
right be self-taught machine learning to
try and crack these problems and we did
crap this problem we created a single
cell aging clock with comparable
accuracy to methylation clocks so there
was you know there was hardly a deficit
and but it was single cell so i think
this was
i don't want to write the history books
right but i think we were first i think
we were first like having a single cell
aging club
and it's not probabilistic basis like we
actually we actually get really robust
measurements like a single cell level
and we're like wow we've done it and i
think yeah the sort of the secret sauce
um
and i've i've been told to remain
stealthy on the details right because
everybody's migrated to sort of
commercial entities but and
it was basically noise reduction gene
expression is noisy if you can get rid
of the noise you can you can start
seeing biology properly like in focus
and so that that was mostly
um and then we were like wow we've got
this clock like let's do the christmas
screen it's like wow all of a sudden
yeah we're ready to do this christmas
screen
and it but it was actually a
mathematician that pointed out something
that was should have been blindingly
obvious to us as biologists which was
the biology
sitting inside this clock because it was
built out of genes
there was a lot of biology to look at
because genes are easy you know because
it's easy to experimentally interrogate
genes relatively easy right you can
overexpress a gene
knock out a gene see what the impact is
you know many phd students work on genes
and proteins right you know they get
lumps with them or they enjoy working on
them
but there was you know there's there's a
lot of work that's been done on genes
and unlike methylation
sites where it's very hard to
experimentally interrogate a single
methylation site and show that it's
linked to this and that like the tools
don't exist experimentally that they're
starting to be developed right there are
methylation editing but it's still the
experimental stage but genes are
fantastic so
the mathematician basically pointed out
oh look sitting inside your clock are
aging biology like there's genes yeah
there's like those genes that are known
aging biology so there were
mitochondrial genes
there were ribosomal genes so there's a
ribosomal
ribosomal clock um like on its own
creates a clot from bernardo lamos at
harvard so and there was a gene that on
its own uh creates progeria in humans
right sitting inside our aging club
and when we realized that the the
interesting thing the more interesting
thing about this clock wasn't using it
as a readout for a christmas screen it
was the cogs inside the clock which is
these jeans which is you know it's like
a window into the aging biology
and and then all of a sudden we were
like
that's that's actually more interesting
because
um you've arrived at this collection of
genes
um without going through a construction
and combinatorial space so when you do a
christmas screen you're actually just
knocking things out one by one yeah so
your combinatorial space actually very
limited but with machine learning you
have a completely open view of like it
could be hundreds of genes or it could
be just a few and so you sort of you can
throw in that to everything and the
machine learning basically brings in
it's a composite of a set of genes that
correlate
and we realize this is well here's a
potential window into biology
that is not combinatorially constrained
and we've done it we don't have to spend
a penny yeah and you know the christmas
screen is still going to be expensive
and so we were like well you know let's
take what we think is this aging pathway
and flip it into reverse in an aged
system
we'll see what happens
and around this time i think there was a
lot of noise about cellular
reprogramming yeah so i think we were
aware of tamiya chandra who'd like he
deserves more credit right because he
took two things which were breakthroughs
which was the yamanaka factors
and the uh epigenetic agent clock and he
put them together and he showed you know
that yamanaka factors can reset the
clock all the way down to zero like just
within a few weeks where they can bring
it down to zero so he basically he
qualified cellular reprogramming as the
ultimate rejuvenation paradigm and
that's his contribution
um
so
oh god lost my fred
that's all right i can intervene um so
so far you've generated this plug based
on gene expression using machine
learning and so initially you developed
based on mouse data as i guess two
initial questions from my side is
firstly
are you still working in milestone lines
at the moment and also how does it take
into account as we've noticed before
different tissue types and how it's like
aging isn't just one tissue aging as
different organs aging maybe at
different rates
and
does that mean you have multiple
different clocks for different tissues
or have you been able to just make one
universal
like gene expression clock
yeah so we started in mice because it
was publicly available data and we could
just go everywhere in that data set like
we could ask these types of questions
like can you make clocks for everything
or is it still very tissue specific um
it's actually it's a bit of a middle
middle ground so
um
without without the the special source
right you you can create a
a clock for a particular cell type in a
particular tissue
that's accurate right but it just falls
apart right even in the same cell type
in a different tissue that falls apart
yeah but if you add the secret source
you can actually make that clock work
pretty much as well in the same cell
type in a different tissue so we're able
to cross that bridge you know which is
like the same cell type but in a
different tissue we can make a clot that
way so it's not multi-tissue
it's like multi-cell type multi-tissue
single cell type multi-tissue and we
won't really be able we couldn't really
create multi-tissue clocks
um
with gene expression data right we never
we we never tried very hard because we
we were more focused on something else
which sort of came into play so um
so that's as far as we got as far as
multi-tissue is concerned um
but then there are human data sets
there's single-cell transcriptomics for
uh
fibroblasts of different ages so we
looked in there and it does look pretty
similar i think it's nerve basel i
commented that even though age link
diseases like say you try something in a
mouse model in asian disease it doesn't
translate very well aging
biology seems to be remarkably conserved
between species like much more
conservative than the asian diseases are
okay um so it doesn't mean that you know
we're exactly the same as a mouse but
we're more like a mouse as far as aging
is concerned
and than alzheimer's is concerned or
something like that but human cells are
our focus right we're not doing this for
the mice so yeah you know once we got
something to work in mice it was like
human cells immediately so there was
some human fibroblasts we looked at an
aging time causing human fibroblasts
pretty much spat out the same sort of
thing and with a few exceptions
but then we realized that uh
you know aging is just a black box and
we've created a method that we can point
out black box and it creates a
prediction of the biology right that's
operating inside that box
and there was almost a
as if not more exciting black box um
called cellular reprogramming so this is
you know this is you can rejuvenate with
yamanaka factors so these factors
originally discovered
for their ability to take an adult so
i'll make it into a stem cell
and but temperatures show that you
actually reset the clock in the process
so this this whole thing is a black box
with a few exceptions so we just pointed
the method at this black box
and it creates a prediction of the of
the biology right and it's actually
fascinating you know there's actually an
overlap between the aging side and the
sony reprogramming side
and
ironically my mitochondria mitochondria
say you know like you know that's where
i came from originally and it's almost
i'm trying to transcend the hypothesis
based approach
but they crop up um and
i mean that's that's that's that's
enough that's enough to say but
i guess that is how we arrived at you
know what our prediction the pathway is
and for us now is really
his here's a prediction the pathway
let's let's rigorously test this
experimentally which is like let the
cells tell us that we're
on onto something or you know if it
doesn't work that's valuable information
we can change the way we model things to
make sure we actually get some
information but i guess for us the
moment we can rejuvenate without young
lack of factors it doesn't matter
whether it's still slightly dangerous
you know we can rejuvenate without the
lack of factors there's basically a
triangulation we can do where we just
sort of really end over a period of time
there's a certain process we're putting
together which is that you know that's
why i have to sort of end
and the details and
but that's yeah that's it we've got this
prediction
might work might not work the first time
but we we've got a few ways to try and
make it work but the moment we get
something that isn't young fat is just
triangulated from different paradigms
and you know it gets very interesting so
one thing i guess i would want you to
elaborate a bit on is why not yamanaka
factors and i think it comes down to the
idea about safety and i guess that could
lead on to a conversation of the
cellular reprogramming but the different
extents to which you can reprogram a
cell um such that it doesn't fully like
lose its identity um and could become
essentially cancerous and i get on from
that if you want to discuss about
how you foresee the work you're doing at
shift bioscience being applied
therapeutically what would be like the
kind of vision down the line as to how
you would use this information and
be using it to treat aging
sure so yeah sort of speaking about the
young lack of factors and the safety
dimension so
um i think it's useful that there are
people you know there's companies that
are trying to take something that works
and do something useful with it yeah and
the concern for me which is you know
that's just our position is that the
safety window is just too narrow at the
moment yeah so
you know we've got this black box which
is it's an amazing black box right we
can rejuvenate with this black box but
it remains a black box and these are
quite powerful factors right they affect
some identity and we don't really want
to be
doing too much in our cell right you
know in living people we want to we want
to be very precise about what we do we
don't want to be activating all these
other things you know we don't want
these off-target effects
so
for us it just seems obvious if you've
got a black box and you want to increase
the safety window let's figure out what
the rejuvenation pathway is inside of
because that's the best way to be
precise we find out what that particular
pathway is target that specifically just
have a greater safety window so i guess
in the long term we're not we're not
running these huge risks these you know
ultimately getting a drug into people's
hands
where you can say reset your biological
age back to prime of life
and that's a very long road it's going
to take a lot of money and these are
very simple things we can do early i
mean they're not they're not simple yeah
but um we do have tools that allow us to
give ourselves the best possible chance
of finding out what that pathway is and
removing the safety problems so you know
you know i'm sure there is a there is a
window for using yamanaka factors um
but i think it's quite narrow
and you know by all means somebody
proved me wrong because it's fantastic
right we can get the rejuvenation
benefit
um without without the nasty side
effects but it just seems obvious here's
a black box which is dangerous let's
look inside of it and get rid of the
dangerous spin
and i guess we you know maybe maybe
we're procrastinating a bit about it but
i think that is for us that's the long
term project and
so that's sort of that's speaking about
the safety side the yamanaka factors
and then i think your secondary the
second question was sort of like how do
you envision this exactly yeah so um my
favorite person at the moment is called
now barachian so he heads up flagship
pioneering which was the
company that created moderner so it's
like company creation sort of venture
venture capital fan
and
he's got a great quote which is uh he
says that what just happened to the
world
is the combination of the fast pandemic
of covet 19 with the slow pandemic of
chronic disease so it's a collision of
those two right which is really the big
problem so there's a solution for the
fast pandemic which is the vaccines
right you know you know all of a sudden
we have these vaccines um in quite a
short amount of time but there is no
solution for
the slow pandemic um of chronic disease
what he's really talking about is aging
yeah you know that's the cradle of these
chronic diseases so
the interesting thing is if you can
crack that that problem right the the
slow pandemic it actually
cracks the other problem which is the
fast pandemic because young is you know
the concern is the um severe reactions
to covered right you just young people
just you probabilistically just don't
get as many severe reactions if you're
much younger you don't really suffer
covered right it just comes and it goes
yeah with exceptions but you know so if
you could you could actually solve the
slow pandemic you'd end up solving both
of them um
and the problem is if you don't solve
the slow pandemic everything starts to
feel like a pandemic i imagine we all
start aging by a larger proportion of us
become aged which is the trajectory at
the moment
every level of things we're going to
become more and more dangerous the older
that you get yeah so things that we
don't call pandemic now will become
yeah the effects will be the same as
like you know what happened just now so
you know
malabar asians recognize this you know
someone needs to deal with the snow
pandemic but i think you know you know
you've recognized this we recognize this
he's just reframing it in a really
useful way
and something he he does which is very
useful it's called future backwards
planning you know so here's this place
we want to go
and how do we get there right you know
as opposed to let's let's just do
something proximal to what we're doing
you know and then just do something
proximal again like that's that's not
necessarily where breakthroughs come
from you know it's almost like here's
like here's where we want to go
how do we pull
ourselves into this reality so
um anyway it's a useful mindset and so
you know like if we start with where we
want to go
you know like what where do we want to
go with shift right like what is the
ultimate or what's the ultimate um goal
imagine in the future it's a little bit
like over 19 right it's like this
parallel system so we covered 19 you do
these lateral photos you know just make
sure you haven't got covered well that's
fine you haven't got it
and
or you know you take you take mrna
vaccines as well to make sure you don't
get it
and so imagine in the future you have an
equivalent test and you know
i guess uh yeah you take a swab and you
drop those uh droplets on that little
bit sponge it goes up
far too much detail
and but instead of saying whether you've
got coded a lot it says oh you're in the
danger zone by danger zone like you're
within five years of a cardiac event
right or five years within early signs
of dementia
and so you get that result and
all of a sudden um you go and get a mrna
vaccine so we we anticipate that we have
combinatorial mrna therapeutic targeting
a set of you know say three to four
safe rejuvenation genes so you go and
get your
uh you know again it's just an injection
like the vaccines and you take a
follow-on test and you say you know are
you out of the danger zone
maybe you're not maybe you got too far
into the danger zone and you need
something that's a bit more specialized
which is
you know it deals with the aging that
also deals with the disease-specific
nature of what you've got so maybe
you're more towards alzheimer's more
towards heart disease so there's a you
know a slightly more uh tailored
version which is
you know like rejuvenation plus
you know a reversal of whatever that
disease is yeah so but you can see
that's that's the sort of future you
could imagine
and then you know how do we get there
right that's that's the key thing future
backwards
uh so in the very short term
what we're just trying to do is like
find out what this rejuvenation pathway
is right inside of cellular programming
and this rejuvenation paradigm is just
like the most powerful of the ones that
are out there it's the most it's
dangerous as well yeah it's a
double-edged sword
it's powerful but it brings dangers
but you know say we find this pathway
that's step one but then we need to find
the the key
nodes right because yeah
for a therapeutic you can't be targeting
30 genes simultaneously it's just too
much complexity too many things and you
want something like a set of three to
four you know like you know like young
laker factors like there's three or four
people can use those and induce those so
we want to find from an intervention
perspective a set of three to four genes
and we think it's going to be a
combinatorial rna therapeutic
and there's a question over which tissue
you target first and we've got various
ideas about this but you know i think
there's various conversations about
where to go i think the brain is a very
good place
and to go first because
it's relatively satellite um to
alternative rejuvenation paradigms so
for instance young blood you know so you
know the idea of a change in blood
composition which is inherently more
translatable than what we're talking
about here so just changing by plasma
composition and there's a fascinating
study i think steve orbath and howard
catch him
where they they show that you can
basically rejuvenate the clock by
over 50 in lots of different tissues but
the brain stands out because it doesn't
seem to get as much benefit from that
rejuvenation so
you know or whatever's going on in the
blood it's it's communicated to the
heart i think it's one of the organs the
liver and the organ it doesn't seem to
reach the brain so you've got this sort
of niche that is not
reached by whatever's in the young blood
and so you know like that's a nice niche
to
create a targeted therapy right let's
get to the brain and of course you know
there's lots of scary things that happen
to the brain with aging
so i mean that's where we are at the
moment but and i think i think we've got
plenty of flexibility as we move forward
to take on information
and you know there's lots of people
there's no rule book at the moment right
it's just you know like um
do you treat pets or is it um
you know rejuvenate the reproductive
system there's lots of ways
to try and go about this
but the encouraging thing is that
young blood has actually made great
inroads for diseases of the brain right
this is the amazing thing even though
the biological age isn't that much
reduced
i think it's tony whisker
with alkahest and there's something
called the amber study so in parkinson's
and alzheimer's you can actually affect
endpoints and those diseases just with
young blood even though you're not
affecting the biological age component
very much
so you know even when you're doing
small things you're affecting these
diseases imagine if we brought the age
of the brain down
all the way right like you know the way
that other organs are benefiting like
what that could do right as far as your
risk of those diseases so that's my
inclination at the moment but
um we don't need to cement to mount that
right now but there will be a stage like
not actually that that far in the future
uh the timelines are all of this so
uh i think one year to get to
rejuvenation without yamalaka factors
um
uh another year to
basically get a fully the wrist version
right so we we find what the nodes are
and these these are these are like safe
nodes from what we can activate so two
years for that and then
sort of three to four years to go from
like here's what we want to target to
you know you have to just go through the
pre-clinical development government yeah
so like model systems toxicity
fun and id filing
and ultimately we want to you know we're
very you know absolutely
uh deadly serious about doing this we
want to get all the way to dicing the
first phase one trial
uh i guess the timelines are sort of uh
you know five five to six years
but that's you know i'm a scientist
right so this is borderline speculation
but we you know we've got
very very very recently a lot of
expertise now
providing their view sort of informing
these timelines a bit better but
i wouldn't worry too much about the time
it's about getting it right you know i'd
right yeah it's better to have a fully
de-risked therapy that goes the distance
instead of rushing something through
development that fails later and that's
that sets back everybody right you know
whenever 300 million dollars goes up in
smoke
and somebody else comes along with the
real answer yeah they're less you know
it's a problem so i think a bit of
patience at the earliest stages actually
pays dividends in the long run but
obviously we want these things as soon
as possible um you know not personally
i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not
confronting the abyss but you know on
the chef team for instance uh steve
who's that you know my dad he's
he's much
he's much closer to these sorts of
things and he tells me from the front
lines of aging you know it's uh
you wouldn't recommend it
you won't recommend it yeah well that
sounds yeah super exciting and that
you're right i think it's important to
focus on the safety but also
you're right but also not cementing on a
solid idea and just seeing where you
know the information takes you and i
think that's the wise way of approaching
it and so speaking of like just
you know being in charge of running at
this company like also you know you like
me did biochemistry um as training like
how did you cope with becoming you know
ceo of a company and what kind of
challenges do you face in this position
yeah so it's quite a big switch from
being an academic scientist to a ceo and
i think one of the things that i should
have focused on in hindsight is
communication so when you come out of
the lab you're actually quite a scary
creature but nobody
like you you don't actually you're not
you can't really communicate with normal
people you can communicate in a robotic
sense with other phd students and things
like that but when you talk to other
people they you can see their eyes
yeah
so the communication side i sort of
ignored this for a little bit but quite
quite quickly it was you know you need
to be a bridge builder like very quickly
like in in that position where you're
sort of trying to bring together say
capital and your ideas and stuff like
that i'm very fortunate that in the you
know there's an entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial
spirit in the family and my dad's doing
this and this might be
more normal to me than it would to be to
somebody else so i could just sort of
just ask him a bunch of questions
um but yeah communication
was like that that was that was the
you know playing catch up right like
actually communicating properly
and with normal
normal people not you know nobody's
nobody there's no such thing as normal
but
um
just just other people that could help
us
and we are fortunate our first investor
was a scientist first right so he was a
scientist and then became an
entrepreneur so i could sort of talk to
him as a scientist i didn't really have
to worry too much about talking to him
and getting that investment but then
later on we had to involve others uh
sort of this communication issue and we
the thing is we stayed as a very small
team for quite a long time so when we
set up in 2017 there's just two of us
i think we expanded to only three people
and it was only in 2021 where we're like
you know we doubled the size of the team
we're still on a large team
still pretty small but it's still you
know it's a big change very quickly
um and then
communication becomes even more
important
that's that's you know both internally
and then
trying to
talk to people on the outside and you
know it's basically storytelling i think
i'm just gonna recycle a bunch of advice
i've been given um but i think
there was a survey it's like um
you know what you might appreciate most
from a pitch and it's like is it data is
it story plus data or is it just the
story and most people vote story like
they sort of want to opt into the detail
they don't want you to download your
entire brain on top of them because
they'll just you know just don't even
know they can't swim in that while they
drown um so if you you know eventually i
just just told the story and
that was enough and you could you know
everything sort of floated much easier
but you know i'm a first time founder so
i'm sort of learning
on the fly
i don't feel like i'm in a position to
give advice apart from the fact that you
know we're still going and it's going
really well
how long may it last um but yeah also i
think communication is the big one i
think so uh thinking about trying to
grow the team bigger oh absolutely yeah
so so all of a sudden we our bottleneck
was financial so we had we had the whole
plan in place and we just needed to go
right we needed uh to just order a bunch
of jeans like do all this stuff or get
equipment
and and we've been able to close our
round relatively recently
and now it's recruitment right like
we've got the fuel
um
this is great it's a great problem to
have right like you've actually fueled
to
complete the mission that you set out to
complete like you know we feel like
we're very fortunate to have raised the
money so no normal companies raise the
money so we're very fortunate to be in
that
category that did
actually that the much harder task is
than taking that money and executing on
the plan but that's an even smaller
number of companies right there's plenty
of contenders but then who actually gets
there so now's the really hard bit right
you know actually getting down into the
really
difficult and boring and dirty
day-to-day of molecular biology
and if you've done a phd you just
understand how hard it is to get things
to work and how tedious things are and
how unrewarding like you basically have
to live
with the fact that you're not going to
get any
like positive feedback like you're not
going to get any reward from your
experiments you basically have to just
like um get over it yeah like you know
you're not you don't get to tell the the
biology what what it should do or
persuade or anything
and like you know if you're lucky as a
phd student in the fourth year you've
actually got something to show for that
effort there's many phd students never
you know the biology never
reveals itself yeah and it's it's
actually it's very character building
but it's this harsh reality that i think
um
yeah that you need to you sort of build
that into your system before you
get too excited about what might come in
the future you've got these very hard
things you've got to do first so i think
everybody in our team
and we we can all go into cell culture
if necessary and do the dirty and boring
work sort of stand them for each other
so i don't know if that's unique in the
field or not but i like i like to think
that gives us a
credibility or you know like you know we
we we can all stare at the cold face of
this uh it's just you know this this is
a big problem we're confronting right
it's not we can't wish it away with
taglines and things like that you know
it's like it's rigorous
application of processes and techniques
and things like that yeah i think
teamwork is essential in science and
just being on the same wavelength for
people and helping each other out when
you need it
and i guess that yeah kind of makes you
unique being small and everyone knows
each other really well and i guess that
kind of forces that kind of relationship
within the team yeah this is this this
is the useful side of a small team you
become like the special forces unit you
know um where
you know you can finish each other's
sentences
um everything just flows very quickly
and you do lose that a bit with scale so
it's not necessarily more is more you
know i think at the stage we are right
now i think we're actually a fantastic
team to make this next step
the moment we reach say rejuvenation
without your macro factors it becomes a
much bigger
undertaking that requires lots of people
and a lot of expertise we don't have
currently
um but we were only ready for that once
we've got that first that first signal
on light from these experiments yeah so
i mean as you kind of mentioned there
are like other companies that are also
interested in like cellular
reprogramming um what are your thoughts
on it do you think there's plenty to
research and it's like not a big deal or
just excited to see like other people in
the face i think it's huge validation
for this space because you know
we've been interested for a long time
and
but now you've got people
that i guess the difference is the
the type of people that are talking
about this now
they've got a much larger audience right
and you know you know the audience
includes like all of the best venture
capital fan plan it's coming from the
right mouth you know like it's not
enough for me to say this is real we
should do this right when it comes from
somebody else actually it's a huge sort
of uh
um
it's like it's like the tide that lifts
all boats right and i think there's
basically i think this is a very good
thing uh
there's plenty of room on the front
lines right basically what we've got in
front of us is infinite failure space
where we're trying to find this biology
right like it's not
you can't just roll the dice
over and over again yeah and i hope you
arrive at the answer because failure
space is infinite and the success space
is tiny
so
i think as many approaches as possible
is a good thing
like we know we're very focused on
creating a vehicle to explore this huge
space as opposed to just firing things
off in different directions and hoping
it hits so like you know basically build
the vehicle that allows you to pilot
towards
or away from you know obviously towards
the biology and so it's now variation
talks about emergent discovery and
all these sorts of things and
but yeah i think it's i think it's a
it's a very
it's a very exciting time right now you
know like right now
because you know we've been we've been
going with chef since 2017 and just the
intensity of like
developments uh publications or
excitement like you know mainstream
excitement has just ticked up in 2020
world in particular i think this year at
the beginning of this year we had this
all hands
meeting where it was like
all we've got to do this year is focus
it's a cliche i have the tiger there's
this whole thing going on around us
right all we need to do is put one step
in front of the
and everything else follows because you
know the fundamentals aren't moving
forwards right this whole thing can go
away as fast as it arrived but you know
the fundamentals move forwards
everything else is good you know you
know so
you've got to ruthlessly focus on that
it's actually incredibly hard to do that
day to day when all these fantastic
things are happening around you yeah and
obviously we're in proximity to that
whereas we're at cambridge
altos institute and uh
you know our advisor is
now going to be part of that and it's a
fantastic thing but it's it's also a
deep focus so we're trying to you know
how do we stay focused and i guess as
scientists this is a great thing about
our team we're all scientists
and our source of energy is
exploring the unknown you know like
finding things out for the first time so
you know we built this vehicle and we
get to
all get on board this vehicle and see
things for the first time and i think
it's going to be this like natural focus
you know like where we
we basically you know we just perhaps go
away for a little bit or whatever you
want to call it stealth you know we just
go in because we're just we're just sort
of driving our vehicle and having a
great time and then you know
ideally landing out on some safe
rejuvenation biology
and then you know when we're there
everything else is good yeah and uh you
know we can we can do what we need to do
at that stage and so yeah for us this is
the critical step right now but it's a
fantastic time and i'd encourage people
to get involved don't see
like a big big company landing in the
space as like a
you know like as a warning not to get
involved it should it should sort of
speak volumes to the uh solidity of the
science right and the credibility of the
field and things like that um i think
more
more minds on this is a really good
thing yeah and i completely agree and
like
yeah one of the reasons why i am still a
scientist is i like being the first one
to see your name something that no one
else has seen before this is super
exciting and so i guess like despite
your your extreme focus do you have like
other interests in different areas of
like aging biology at the moment or
yeah so i'd say um young
blood based approaches so you know
changing blood plasma composition
is you know uh as far as translatability
is concerned it's amazing right because
you're just you're just changing the
levels of natural factors right in the
blood
um and
in model systems you can achieve like 50
percent rejuvenation it's not like 15
50.
that's a big chunk of rejuvenation with
something that's inherently translatable
and it's fascinating i think again tony
whiskery he he did a study um using
single cell transcriptome
you know um sort of machines
so he was trying to find out what is the
functional pathway that's upregulated by
young blood right now so these mice are
benefiting but
you know as far as the cells are
concerned what's happening it's actually
a very surprising result and it's a very
focal result which was mitochondrial
like genes go up fight and and again
it's like you know it's like i'm trying
to
trying to get away from being
pigeonholed as a mitochondriologist
right because i didn't serve this one at
the beginning but like just keeps
cropping up so like you know young blood
you see these mitochondrial genes we see
them on
you know i'm not saying that that's the
only
part of the story there's plenty of
other interesting things going on but i
guess it's a nice
connection to what i did previously i
mean but mitochondria there's so many
different
things you can study like they fuse to
each other it's whole dynamics
there's dynamics as the genome you know
most of the genome actually migrated to
the nucleus so most of the genes are
actually
built outside the mitochondrion imported
right
um
so you still have this tiny genome where
if you you know anyway there's so many
facets it's like you could just like
narnia yeah you just go in there and get
lost and never come out which is you
could you could you know i'll make the
argument that's perhaps why i was
blinking at the beginning
um
so yeah you either love mitochondria or
you know nothing about it you know so
there's very few people in the middle
ground
but yeah i'd say youngblood's very very
interesting and uh
yeah i think i i think that will be the
first
type of therapy to cross the finishing
line as in
a rejuvenation mechanism intervention
that is clinically approved not not for
aging maybe for something else like a
specific agent disease but be the first
rejuvenation mechanism
and drug
um you know it's across the finishing
line i might be wrong but i i'm you know
i think that will be it
and that will do a lot of good for other
therapies that will follow because you
know the moment somebody crosses the
finishing line then it becomes about
effect size where do you get effective
side you need to know what the biology
is
how do you know what biology is yeah
that's that's what we're working on
so
you know
the other side of this has this huge
huge flourishing industry right like you
know once you can uh sort of rejuvenate
sales and do these different things like
it just becomes this brand new massive
industry in all different directions
and there's so much you know it's just
it's it's not a zero something you know
it's like
a space it's like infinite space right
like it's just it's up to you
how far you can go with what you're
doing
and i think just
yeah if you're smart and you're excited
about this like get involved as soon as
possible
well yeah i think that's a great way to
try and summarize this discussion up um
it's been a great talking to you today
in learning more about shift and its
mission and like how it's approaching uh
the different questions it's trying to
ask and so i guess just a final thing
where can people go to find more
information about you and to reach out
and hear more about the shifts
sure so
go to our website it's just
chefbioscience.com
and i also gave a talk to the foresight
institute longevity group
um that goes into
a bit more detail and that might be um
it might be fun to watch uh it's a
fairly lengthy video but
there's a bit more of our story there
with some visuals
and
we are recruiting at the moment for free
priority positions
and so my email address is daniel chef
bioscience.com
so that's just a bottleneck for us so um
sorry to be able that we're really
really really there but
that would really that would really help
us you can edit that out if you want not
the false
um there's some great songs today i just
really appreciate the time you've taken
yeah speak for me i'm sure my viewers
found it very interesting as well
very welcome very welcome so i hope
you've learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you